with a background of unprecedented
uh increase in uh
as a response to the aggressive actions
of the nato and western partners
i just would like to emphasize that
nobody wants a war nobody ever even
wants to make the situation worse
neither russians
nor
people of belarus
the initiative for worsening of the
situation comes from
ukraine and we
are
on the verge of a conflict
which would involve
the whole continent
we
see that
irresponsibility of a number of western
leaders
has led to to the situation and we see
that this irresponsible or irrational
behavior of our neighbors
has led to this situation
vladimir putin
was quite
soft talking about the conflict in
donbass but we see that people already
fleeing this
region and this is not normal i have the
um
i have an impression
that
certain
politicians
from the so-called free world
they are
quite dangerous
uh then dangerous for
those who surround them and for their
own people
the next few
days we will complete our military
drills planned military drills
and
tomorrow we have a joint
event on the territory of russian
federation which uh
media will be informed about as for the
completing drills
i explained the essence of the trailers
and the president mentioned it just now
in the context of increasing danger
in the context of
ukraine being filled up with foreign
and russia have to
take measures and there's nothing
surprising about this
we have to be careful there's uh
about 1.5 000 kilometers of border
we have joined
centers for preparing
forces of the union state and all of
these documents
all of these uh
areas uh have never been hidden and
everyone is aware of these so
these drills
are justified by the
situation and they are conducted in a
transparent way on our own territory
and
it is being conducted
under under a whole army of attaches and
media
we also
talked
about the integration of the of the two
countries
four months since we signed the main
agreement
and we have uh
programmed for 2123.
we have moved forward in implementing
those programs of integration
what has been done
in terms of these programs this has been
covered extensively and the president
also covered it
we focused our attention on the
following areas tax
customs
and forming the joint
gas market
those who are fighting
the sanction war
will have to suffer most in this
gangster approach due to this
in the in the field of
economics in the field of finance
through these sanctions
we've already learned how to counteract
them and how to act and work in this
context
we have to
work to resist the sanctions
and i am grateful to the president putin
for the instructions that you gave to
the
um
to the
government of the russian federation in
my presence
without hiding anything from me i'm
grateful to you for that